[Music]
it's safe to say that we use had a
sparse year with the switch on the way
Nintendo's clearly shifting its
development focus elsewhere since the
term of the year I so love around 150
games of release for the Wii U but it's
difficult to name more than a handful as
indie darlings like odd world Abe's
Oddysee new and tasty old reliable the
Lego titles like Lego Star Wars The
Force awakens and the odd big
third-party port like Minecraft story
mode but nothing really huge immediately
comes to mind luckily for you
game SWAT has done the digging for you
so let's take a look at the 5 best games
the Wii U had to offer and its last full
year in the limelight pokken tournament
is a bizarre pokemon Tekken crossover
and offers Pokemon found something
they've been dreaming of since the
series inception in 1996 characters
actually fighting until now Pokemon
games had only shown the monsters
performing small movements in battle
pokken tournament finally showed series
favorites like chars island Jenga
physically heating each other giving the
fighting game a sense of impact that
some say the franchise had lacked it
stayed faithful to the game's tactical
roots too with mega evolutions support
characters and a two-phase attack system
meaning you'll need to be quick in your
head
as well as in your fingers to succeed
and it does all this without
overwhelming your players which is
important because although it's
definitely a hardcore fighting game many
people playing will simply be big fans
of Pikachu just like you and me
next up is another crossover this time
between Shin Megami Tensei and Fire
Emblem Tokyo Mirage sessions takes the
plot and relationship building of a
Megami Tensei or persona game but the
rest is unmistakably Fire Emblem so
while demons are attempting to take over
the world and you've got to make friends
to beat them the characters weapons and
skill upgrades are all from Fire Emblem
a crossover like that could have felt
weird with art styles and gameplay
systems clashing but developer Atlas has
beautifully merged two games into a
great dungeon crawler in fact the
characters and mechanics are married so
well and this strange mashups tsoi's it
feels like the two franchises were
always destined to be together you might
not have heard of axiom verge but it's
easily one of the best Wii U games this
year
it's a side-scrolling indie Metroidvania
developed by just one man all by himself
being made by one man army didn't hinder
axiom though it's mysterious plot soon
drools you in before knew perfectly
balanced mechanics and items push you on
small drones grappling hooks and laser
drills allow you to explore new parts of
the world if you're good enough that is
the amount of Secrets you discover even
affects the ending you get so there's a
reason to go back again and again it's
well worth a playthrough or five another
indie game reaches the top 5 in steam
world heist if you're unaware
imagine XCOM as a 2d side-scroller and
your crew is a ragtag squad of robots
each character has a unique special
ability plus their own kooky sense of
humor and if we mention the robots are
powered by steam yeah they're pretty
cool but it's the fact that it's XCOM in
2d that's the real hook here
not many strategy games are presented
this way but somehow it works
weapons lack any auto aim - so an
element of skill comes in to the
shooting so you can't blame it on a dice
roll if you miss
last up we've got Paper Mario Color
Splash a game that seemed to fly under a
lot of people's radars when it launched
in October some fans were upset that it
appeared similar in style to Paper Mario
sticker star on 3ds happily however
color splashes are delight it cuts down
on the text-heavy nature of some
previous Mario RPGs and even has too
deep a perfects to rival tear away above
all it brings a sense of humor to many
games forget and much like Nintendo
itself is heartwarming to the core
[Music]